will is here will what's up man
hey brother what's going on
head back to school this afternoon so
i'm stoked
let's go good weekend now will is going
back to school i feel like everyone
forgets all time that uh you still have
like another life outside of bitcoin but
what no one is gonna forget is you got
that sweatshirt on the day one best
business show hoodie absolutely love to
see it all right let's jump into uh on
chain metrics and i think kind of the
first takeaway really is just
accumulation still is showing to be
really really strong uh across all these
different metrics right
yeah for sure um you know obviously this
is something that we've been looking at
for a while um but you know there's a
couple different ways we can break this
down for a while we had just been
looking at the liquid supply shock ratio
and what that is it's essentially a
ratio of the amount of bitcoin held by
strong hands compared to weak hands or
as glass node puts it a liquid and
liquid and highly liquid entities but
you know just for layman's terms just
saying strong and weak hands i think is
is pretty sufficient um so that's one
way to look at it more of like a um
a qualitative way to look at like where
the coins are moving right and and so
when you look at this ratio i mean it's
been moving up pretty strong over the
last um you know two three weeks as
we've been covering but um it's now at
what previously marked bitcoin at at
price levels of 55 to 57 k so i still
think like this still hasn't fully been
priced in yet although we have been
starting to see it you know get priced
in over the last two weeks
um next we have the uh the exchange
supply shock ratio so
um well the previous was was more like a
qualitative way to look at the supply
shortage this is more of a
you know quantitative way just literally
looking at the amount of coins that are
available to be bought versus the amount
that aren't so the amount of coins that
are on exchanges versus uh you know
measured against the the overall
circulating supply
and so you know you're seeing an uptick
in this
as well and then third we have the
long-term holder supply shock ratio
this is a very similar to the liquid
supply but this is looking at um the
ratio of coins held by long-term holders
versus short-term um and so
the ratio that glasnode uses to cut this
off is 155 days because they've like
done some statistic research on uh just
the fact that like once you get right
around that mark the the likelihood of
more participants moving those coins out
of their wallet kind of drops off
and so like for anybody who wants to
like look into the nuance of it they
have a research article published on
their website
so you know you have three different
measures of this accumulation that that
you can look at and they're all pointing
the same thing which is you know really
aggressive buying
and so as we continue to see more and
more buying happening i think that most
people say okay this market structure is
setting up and so the bulls are uh
looking to higher prices and saying you
know kind of the supply squeeze uh
thesis is gonna play out there is uh
critics or uh those that are still
bearish uh and they're really looking at
this as kind of a dead cat bounce i know
that you've done a bunch of work to try
to see you know what are some of the
data points that either uh support the
dead cat bounce theory or actually end
up being um kind of critical of it so
where are you coming out in terms of
could this just be a dead cat bounce
yeah for sure you know i think it's um i
think it's like a logical thought
process and it's something like
everybody has to you know keep in mind
until it's disproven because you can
never you know speak in absolutes and
rule out everything um but you know
looking at i guess the evidence and
trying to build a case i think
there's a pretty strong case against
this being a dead cat bounce and the
reason i say that is because um
you know one of the things that we said
we were looking for like two weeks ago
is okay if we start moving back up are
these long-term holders that have been
buying are they just gonna dump on like
the first opportunity that they get um
and so like the way to look at this is
you know we can look at it a few ways
but the one i threw in the newsletter
this week um was the spent output age
bands so this is literally looking at um
the you know the the the utxos being
spent you know in certain age bands and
so looking at um the age bands of six oh
older than six months which is the
closest i could get to that long-term
holder 155-day cut-off um what you see
is that you know at the end of the bull
market um when you have a dead cat all
of a sudden you know all those long-term
holders pile in and take the exit
liquidity because they say okay i wanna
you know i'm gonna gtfo you know because
prices have bounced up a little bit i
still think we're going much further
down i'm gonna take this opportunity to
just get out of the market
and so that's been one thing that i've
been really looking for and
haven't seen so that's a really positive
sign that you know these these uh
long-term holders that have
um a you know
been in the market for a while or b just
starting to mature into that you know
155-day threshold they aren't um selling
on this ex liquidity so you know that
that in my opinion is a pretty strong
case against it being a dead cat got it
and then when we start to look at our
favorite metric which is uh sopra uh
remind everyone what sopra is and then
kind of what you're seeing there
yeah i feel like uh you and i have been
talking about sober here for like two
months straight uh sopher is basically
just a ratio of um the profit and loss
that bitcoins hold so
what you're basically looking at is you
know are the coins that are being traded
on the day
are they being um
traded in profit or lost in aggregate um
and so you know in in a bull market what
you see is that like every time that
sober dips below one it's a really good
buy opportunity um because people in a
raging bull market there's really low
tendency that they're going to want to
sell at a loss right and then um
conversely in a bear market whenever
sober goes above one you know it's a
good time to trim some because you know
you're in a downtrend people are just
going to sell on any up move that they
get
and so we had been kind of hovering
below one you know since uh the may 19th
capitulation but what we've seen over
the last couple weeks is this moved back
up over the one threshold and then um
we've been looking for two-fold after
that so a we're looking for
a retest of one so um you know price
drops and then we bounce off and hold
that one threshold as support
and then two we were looking for um you
know seeing if we could stabilize above
one which would be a really good time
so far we have gotten that bounce off of
one like a textbook to bounce off of it
and then right now it looks like we're
starting to stabilize i think
maybe need you know a couple more days a
week to really like get full
confirmation but it looks really good so
far got it and then funding rates i know
is something else that you've been
spending a lot of time looking at
yeah so um funding rates is
like in layman's terms it's basically
like the mechanism that pegs the
perpetual swap which is the you know
it's a futures contract pretty unique to
bitcoin in the sense that like it never
expires you know
the reason it exists is
well several part of like because it
clears so fast you know it makes
getting leverage easier um but the
funding rate basically pegs the
perpetual to the bitcoin index price
which is like a weighted average of all
the major exchanges
and so
when funding is below when funding is
negative i should say um what what's
that what's what that is showing is that
um spot is being more is being bid up
more aggressively than the futures and
then conversely when the when funding
rate um is above the spot price you know
your positive funding rates so that's
showing that you know um it's
it's um
[Music]
taking a long position is more
aggressive in the market i guess i would
probably worded that terribly but
what you're looking for is like
prolonged positive funding or prolonged
negative funding um are are both signals
of you know perhaps a reversal and so
throughout like the main phase of the
bull market um we had positive funding
rates like really high positive funding
rates um but then after may may 19th we
had pretty um negative funding rates all
across the board throughout that whole
kind of consolidation um we have started
to see uh funding rates move like
slightly positive again but when you
compare where we are now um you know at
46k compared to where we were in terms
of um funding back in in february at the
same price levels it's just not even
comparable um open interest is still not
at those levels it's it's coming back up
but both of those things especially
funding is really far from where it was
um in february and so like the key
takeaway here is that this rally is
really being spot driven um that's also
reflected in like when you look at uh
bids right you're seeing bids being
moved up and so people are in other
words like respecting the pump right
people are getting kind of impatient you
know people had bids set down at like
35k
we broke out of the range people said
okay yeah maybe i won't get 35k maybe
i'll get a good entry if we retest you
know the top of the range we never
retest the top of the range now people
are moving uh their bids up higher so
yeah like
all in all like
also seeing like the accumulation trends
um i you know i believe that this rally
is really spot driven yeah and then i
know that we've also talked a bunch in
the last couple of weeks about miners
and it feels like uh we can tell a lot
from what they're doing uh you recently
wrote uh one of the best historical buy
signals in the bitcoin space uh and so
when people hear you say that i think
their ears kind of perk up explain what
this uh kind of hash ribbon buy signal
is and then uh kind of what you're
seeing the miners do from an
accumulation standpoint and the hash
ribbon stuff
yeah sure so like first of all um hash
has started to slightly recover you know
we're still obviously very far from
where we were um you know at some peak
in in april early may
but you know we are starting to see a
slight recovery and so
the hash ribbons are basically two
moving averages of hash and so
what it's trying to capture is like when
miners capitulate um and then start
coming back on the network then you have
the
cell pressure subsiding right because
they're you know they're capitulating
you know they're moving off the network
and then that has just that hash rate is
starting to come back on um and so
like in in theory then the cell crack
the force cell pressure comes off right
and so that's what the hash rooms are
looking at looking at the 30 and 60 day
moving average of hash and so whenever
um the 30 day cross is above the 60 day
that's that's the buy signal um and so
like when you go back historically the
hash ribbons have been like one of the
most accurate kind of macro like
multi-month um you know uh time frame
buy signals in bitcoin so yeah we just
did get that buy signal a couple days
ago got it and then last uh
well i guess i got two more questions
one is around the uh minor net position
change uh that seems to be just a
continuation of the trend uh kind of
miners have flipped and just are
continuing to accumulate as much as they
can
yeah exactly just seeing you know
continued accumulation for them
partially because
you know we had this record difficulty
adjustment and then the miners that were
still left on the network were extremely
profitable
and so they really have an incentive to
you know hold the coins that they were
getting right now for pretty much dirt
cheap in comparison to like the energy
output that it took to mine them
previously
got it and then what about uh
transactions i know that previously
you've said uh the number of
transactions on the network would be
kind of the best supporting evidence for
a bearish outlook i don't think you me
my brothers anyone is uh is bearish
that's on this call but uh what what are
you seeing there with uh with the
transactions
yeah for sure um we're starting to see
that trend back up like not in a big way
um not where i would like to see it yet
but you know this is starting to like
slowly grind up um one interesting thing
though is like although we've had fewer
like the number of transactions um we've
we've seen larger transactions so seeing
like really big spikes in in
transactions above um 10 million dollars
in value so obviously you know those are
those are big buyers in the market
moving coins around um and also like the
the fact that we have lower transactions
also shows to me that like we're not in
this speculative mania phase and we were
talking about how you know funding is
low and this is pretty spot driven um i
think this rally is healthy in that
sense um like just the fact that we
aren't in any type of euphoria at all um
it's mostly just you know like big
buyers slowly picking up coins here um
yeah so yeah like that's reflected in in
the size of the transaction so like
transaction volume um and then also when
you just look at um whales holdings so
like over the last two weeks whales have
like added you know i don't know the
number on the top of my head um
let me see here i put down a 107 107
1550 coins um since july 27th um so like
what i did was i took all the entities
so these are like forensically clustered
addresses um and i took all the entities
with more than a thousand bitcoins
the reason i did that is like
i had been throwing in the newsletter
like a thousand to ten thousand or ten
thousand to a hundred thousand
the problem with that is is that
sometimes you get um
you get these movements from
from one cohort to another so like let's
say
you know you had uh 9999 coins in in
this one entity and then i added one
more coin well all of a sudden 10 000
coins get added to the to the 10 to 100
000 cohort so it looks like that cohort
accumulated just 10 000 coins right but
all it was is someone in the lower
cohort under them just added one coin
and so um like
that got really nuanced trying to filter
through that and i just said forget it
i'm just going to take all the large
entities above a thousand to eliminate
that the factor of having those cohorts
kind of like move into each other um and
so like i did that and then filtered out
the uh exchanges obviously great scale
um qbdc um purpose etf and like all the
all the major basically on chain
recognizable entities and so you get
basically like the raw
balance of like big whales um over a
thousand bitcoins and yeah so you've
seen strong accumulation from them as
well the last couple weeks and so like
pairing that with the fact that we've
seen um those large transfers so over
over 10 million dollars in
you know usd value um you know that
that's showing that there's some big
buyers in the market
i love to hear that joe john what
questions you guys got hey well thanks
for doing this uh pump for you to get
back to school i'm sure you're excited
[Applause]
so i had a quick question i saw an
interesting tweet uh from willy woo
yesterday i think you retweeted it also
uh but it was around the supply
distribution of bitcoin and it was
talking about uh if we zoom out and we
look at the last four to five years it
looks like whales those who own a
thousand or more bitcoin have uh dropped
off dramatically from a percentage
standpoint maybe around 35 40 percent
now they represent about 25 of the
supply uh and in the same vein publicly
held entities have increased
dramatically and so have minnows right
those who own less than 10 bitcoin how
do you think about supply distribution
in general and like its impact on
long-term price
yeah sure great question um
like when you like you said when you
look at this plotted out what you see is
you look at retail compared to overall
circulating supply over time the portion
that they hold goes up and then whales
over time are distributing so you know
that that's a good thing in terms of
like the supply distribution it's really
healthy because you don't want obviously
a lot of supply held in the hands of the
few um you know for price purposes
mostly because you know large buyers can
just dump at will and and they have you
know
stronger control over over the price at
least in the in the short term um
and so yeah like seeing that seeing that
distribution over time in my opinion is
going to kind of coincide with some kind
of stability and price because you have
that more even distribution and so
people don't have as much individual
effect on the market i guess yeah and
and i guess so part of that is obviously
from publicly held entities right which
we can go back and forth on whether they
should be considered whales or not but
how do you think about uh their impact
on the supply right so they could uh i
guess do similar they could act in a
similar nature as whales but how do you
think that they uh more of them getting
involved long-term impacts the price
yeah um i guess it kind of depends on
the structure right like when you look
at grayscale grayscale's just pretty
much been a black hole and they've just
taken coins in and they haven't moved
anyhow and they sell some for their two
percent fee but you know in general
they're just a black hole for coins um
but then you have like the purpose etf
and you know those coins can move in and
out all you know because it's pegged in
f so
yeah i guess it just depends on the
entity also like
you know we're looking at these these um
large whale entities but a lot of times
these are representative of a bunch of
small buyers so like
you know the entities for exchanges
right that that um we're looking at
these are actually you know holding
coins for for tens of millions or in
some cases like you coinbase hundreds of
millions of people and so yeah it's like
one entity on the blockchain but when
you actually like break that down you
know it's way more um small guys that
are making up that that one um
large entity that's identified on chain
so like yeah like there's some
limitations to
like the accuracy of this completely
like
in terms of
you know we obviously don't know how
many result participants are on
exchanges and like the exact so like
supply distribution on exchanges so like
i think it should just kind of be taken
with a grain of salt i guess this
information and just knowing that like
we do have that um healthy distribution
over time although like the numbers
aren't perfectly accurate because of
that
yeah directionally i think it's a good
sign john what you got for us
yeah well how you doing
congrats
i'm good are we just congratulating will
for going back to school
making it to another year um
so my question is around like what do
you think is most affected the price in
like the last week or so is it those
large transactions is it the number of
users um like what do you think around
like where we've been i guess say from
the bottom of the bear market
yeah um you know i think like like i
said most of this has been spot driven
um you know we're seeing limited uh you
know like funding rate's been low um
open interest isn't at you know where it
was in the you know main phase of the
bull market earlier this year
um
and so like when you also look at just
order books in general like coinbase has
been bidding really aggressively so
seeing a lot of a lot of buying from
them
um and then in general like you said you
know whales so so i think it's it's a
lot of large buyers that have been uh
pushing the price up in general
but like no kind of like
speculative you know euphoria or
anything like that i think like this
rally is very healthy in that sense um
and yeah it's just been mostly driven by
you know steady spot buying and and
people are just slowly moving bids up um
as you know they're kind of getting
impatient because price is just slowly
kind of grinding up and um i think like
the max payne theory here is like
not that shorts are going to get
squeezed but more so there's a lot of
capital on the sidelines that has been
watching this thing slowly grind up and
they keep thinking they're gonna well
i'm just assuming they probably think
they're still gonna get a good entry um
you know there's a lot of capital still
sitting in uh stable coins you know
tether usbc
um
and so i think like
that that's gonna have more of an effect
on on the upside than any kind of like
short squeeze it's more of like a fomo
squeeze i guess
uh because you have all those people
just watching this thing slowly grind up
they're slowly you know you can see
they're slowly you know putting their
bids up higher and higher um and then
you know at some point i think like the
impatience kind of takes over uh so like
i'm watching closely um something called
the stable coin supply ratio and so
that's kind of like a good way to gauge
um the flow of of stables in and out of
the bitcoin market and like what you
have been seeing over the last couple
weeks is like that it's starting to been
you know that's starting to pick up in
terms of like how much of the uh those
stable coins have started to flow back
into the market so i think like in
patience i guess if i could like sum it
up i think um that that's been kind of
the driving factor here of like people
who wanted to accumulate you know they
were really patient buyers throughout
that range
um you know you saw they would you know
slowly wait to pick up you know around
30k and then you know no rush and i
think that kind of resembled these you
know bigger more uh
mature buyers that they weren't like
rushing into the market
and so
you know they had no problem waiting for
price to slowly grind back down to like
32 to 28k but now they're starting to
realize okay yeah i'm not gonna get that
i'm not gonna get 35 you know so maybe
we'll we'll set some bids at 40 and i
think like you're gonna get this effect
that continues over the next couple
weeks
well before i let you go we gotta ask
the big question what do you think is uh
is price action looking like over the
next week or so and then what is uh
what's kind of your price
thoughts through the rest of this year
we're currently sitting around 45 46 47
000 where are we going
yeah i think over the next week
um
it kind of depends like what derivatives
look like
and so you kind of have to like look at
it as as it comes like if funding just
moons all of a sudden like open interest
moves then you know we probably get a
correction there in in the short term um
so i don't know it's kind of hard to
gauge over the next week i would say
over the next couple weeks higher um
looking at kind of retest 50k as like a
pretty important level i think we could
potentially set you know theoretically a
uh lower high there but i think like if
we get above 50k the the um
the uh legitimacy of like a thesis of
some kind of dead cat bounce i think
really dies down after we get above that
that 50k level partially because it's
like technical support
also because just in general it's a
round number right like you know
sometimes it's as simple as just looking
at like psychological levels in the
market and uh you know round numbers are
always just you know the common thing
that that price finds resistance at so
yeah i think like 50k we'll probably
retest that in the next couple weeks and
then kind of gauging the reaction there
um
and then also like
i built like this this uh on-chain like
pricing model and so it looks at um like
some of these metrics i didn't build but
i just put them all together so it's
looking at like the floor that
historically for all bitcoin um like in
the bottom of the bear market and then
also at the top um and then the mean
between the two and you're looking at
the realized price um anyway i'm
probably like boring people to death
here but there's there's one uh mid
price level that i would be watching
it's um right around 57k right now it's
kind of like
it's sloping up or it's always adding a
couple hundred dollars a day but i think
if we get back above that um then like
it would be full confirmation in my mind
that that we're going much higher um and
then from there if we broke above 57k
like um
i'd probably be targeting the the
mean between realized price in the in
the top price so that's like right
around 92k right now and kind of
grinding slowly uppers so
okay
let's see if we get that confirmation
but over the next couple weeks i think
we test 50. a follow-on to that is uh i
recently was talking to dan held a
couple of guys who really believe in
this like super cycle thesis where
basically they think hundreds of
thousands of dollars of bitcoin by the
end of the year do you buy any of that
um it's hard to tell like
there's so many factors i i would say
though i think like bitcoin moves away
from this four-year cycle i i think
eventually bitcoin just becomes more
free-flowing kind of in correlation to
like real rates and and just in general
you know the raw supply and demand like
i don't think a lot of these
like
overheated signals for the for the
cycles that i look at i think they'll
all get broken at some point whether
it's like this cycle or the next
you know obviously like it's impossible
to say but
i suspect like over time bitcoin will
just become more freely traded amongst
the just ross of you know supply and
demand and trade more in in tandem with
like some of the more macro factors like
you know obviously bitcoin has been
majority uh you know retail driven so a
lot of stuff hasn't mattered but i think
you'll you'll start to move away from
like the four year cycle so yeah like
does that happen this time i know it's
hard to say i guess we'll kind of like
get a greater uh grasp for that towards
the end of the year when we start to see
like
the kind of uh buyers that that announce
i think like
you'll probably have some big buyers
towards towards the latter half of the
year just because like you know the
really strong accumulation we've been
seeing and like these people probably
aren't going to announce until it makes
them look smart to do so like why would
they announce when you know price is
still at like 40k you know they're going
to come out and announce that like
new all-time highs but oh yeah yeah we
bought that down there yeah like what do
you mean
you know they're not going to say it now
when it doesn't make them look really
smart to do so so
i don't know long for short i think it
just depends on uh some like the more
like extraneous factors that we'll
probably get a better grasp on
throughout the year and then obviously
you know whatever's going on with the
with the dollar has a huge impact on
bitcoin right like if all of a sudden
everybody loses trust in the dollar well
then you know that's insanely bullish
for bitcoin um but you know it's really
hard to like i guess call the the timing
in terms of like will that be this cycle
or next
absolutely where can people go follow
you on uh on twitter and uh you've got
the link to uh to the email that people
can subscribe to where you wanna send
them
yeah sure so um my my twitter is w
clementi iii and then um you can click
on uh
i just started the block where
newsletter with them um and then that's
you can see the link in my bio and click
on that we do like the weekly newsletter
it's it's the new letter that i've been
doing just rebranded
awesome man can we give uh can we give
will a little like round of applause as
he goes back to school you know get it
listen don't do anything i would do
don't get too drunk and uh we'll see you
next week man have fun
i appreciate it it'll be a good weekend
so i'll touch base at some point let you
know how it's going man but i'm looking
forward to proof of life that's what we
need we need a little life this weekend
hey guys thanks so much for watching
that clip of the best business show make
sure you like and subscribe to the
channel turn on notifications so you
know when we go live every weekday and
then head to sofi.com pomp so that you
can get an account we can get after it